but I I think I'm a huge bow nickel fan  I think he's the future I think he's the  biggest Prospect we've had in uh  probably 10 years Beau Nichols is right  there like if he's a stock I'm in why  why not make bow nickels like the  champion Contender series because it is  a feeder League he's the champion of  That League then just have him get  experience in there and then graduate  him to the big loots I think he's ready  to be honest with you you're fighting in  front of Dana you have that clip of Dana  when he gives you the contract obviously  the fight has to speak for itself and it  certainly did yeah I want to see him  challenged uh in week nine at least to  the extent that he can be  foreign  [Music]